These iconic monuments are
just shouting, screaming at us.
Power, dominance, control.
I feel about this.
I feel so insignificant.
Together these pyramids and
the Sphinx and the temples
create a landscape of power.
NARRATOR: The huge sculpture
protects the necropolis.
A giant symbol of
supremacy believed
by many to have the face
of Khufu's son, Khafre,
owner of Giza's second
largest pyramid.
Despite many visits here,
John has never been up close.
Today he's been
granted special access
to explore its enclosure.
JOHN: It's absolutely inspiring.
I mean, it's just jaw-dropping.
I've waited 50 years to
be here, and now I'm here.
It's just wow.
NARRATOR: 66 feet
high, the Sphinx gazes
east towards the rising sun.
JOHN: I know what it's like
to work with the living rock
and how to carve it.
This would have been a
monumental challenge.
They only had copper
chisels, wooden mallets.
It would have been
a harsh environment.
This dust would have
been everywhere.
And yet the workmen, the
craftsmen, the masons,
they were all willing
participants, loyal to pharaoh.
NARRATOR: It would have taken
thousands of people decades
to construct the epic
monuments of Giza,
but there's no
evidence the pharaohs
enslaved people to build them.
They didn't draw their power
over the people from force.
John believes what stood
these kings apart was
that they inspired devotion.
The sheer volume of stone
has gone into building this,
and each individual block
represents the loyalty
that they had for Pharaoh.
NARRATOR: The huge
monuments of Giza
represent the peak
of the pyramid age.
So why was nothing built
on this scale again?
At the height of Khufu's
reign, reliable seasonal rains
fed the crops that ensured
Egypt's prosperity.
For three months
every year, the Nile
flooded and inundated
the farmland, so farmers
couldn't work the fields.
The farmers were free to help
build the King's enormous tomb.
They believed he kept the gods
content and the country fed.
But soon after Khufu
completed his pyramid,
Egypt began to suffer drought.
As crop yields crashed,
so did the taxes coming
into the state's treasuries,
and despite the free labor
the Giza monuments
almost bankrupted Egypt.
The people's loyalty
began to falter.
The King's tombs that
followed got smaller
while Khufu's Great Pyramid
remained, dominating
the Nile's West Bank.
JOHN: The sheer
power that he held
is absolutely unbelievable.
NARRATOR: It was a power
his struggling successors
were desperate to replicate.
At Abu Ghurab
Italian archeologist
Massimiliano Nuzzola
wants to know
how the kings of the pyramid age
held onto power as their wealth
and status declined.
He has spent his entire career
trying to understand a very
different monumental structure.
An enigma whose
mysteries captured
his imagination in his
very first student course
in Egyptology.
This enormous scatter
of ancient rubble
was once a sun temple
dedicated to the most powerful
god of the pyramid age.
MASSIMILLIANO NUZZOLA:
Each king wanted a pyramid
for achieving his
resurrection but this
was not enough for the
five dynastic kings.
They wanted something more.
The king built this place
to turn himself into a god.
The sun god.
NARRATOR: The Pharaoh
Nyuserre didn't just
want to become divine in death.
He built this temple
because he wanted
to be worshipped as a god
while he was still alive.
Rising from the desert
was an enormous obelisk,
the centerpiece of the temple.
It was not a traditional
slender stone needle,
but shaped more like a pyramid.
Monumental walls
enclosed it creating
a courtyard in which people
could come to worship the sun.
The temple aligned
perfectly on an east west
axis with the path of the sun.
So on the summer
solstice every year,
the sun rose through
the entrance,
traveled directly
over the obelisk,
and set at the Western end.
This alignment is identical
to that of the pyramids.
Records suggest that six of
the pharaohs who followed Khufu
decided to build a sun temple
as well as their pyramid
to underline their divine
status to the people of Egypt.
But almost all of
these temples are lost.
MASSIMILLIANO NUZZOLA:
We know that there were
six sun temples, and
we actually so far
have discovered only two.
NARRATOR: Max hopes excavating
this sun temple will shed light
on these kings
power, and perhaps
help him crack one of the
biggest mysteries in Egyptology
and find the other
missing sun temples.
The problem is, Max is
not the first to decode
this structure's secrets.
Early Egyptologists excavated
here more than 100 years ago,
and left a mess of
archaeological confusion
in their wake.
Well, this find is
amazing because it's
a cover of matches left
by the archaeologists
during their work.
NARRATOR: Along with their
discarded matchboxes,
early 20th century excavators
left 4,500 year old pottery
scattered across the site.
As you can see here,
this area of the temple
is full of pot shells.
But unfortunately this material
is completely useless for us
because it's out of
a secure context.
Cannot tell us anything
about the life of the temple.
NARRATOR: If Max can find
undisturbed artifacts,
they might reveal clues the
first archeologists missed.
Even the smallest
of finds could be
crucial in the hunt for the lost
sun temples of the pyramid age.
[music playing]